you know obviously this is my country
this is my home
and the idea that a big let's face it a
big
chunk of this country does not see me as
american it does not accept me as
american
even though i know it's not the problem
is not with me the problem is with them
it's still a little heartbreaking to me
and it's still
it still gets to me you know uh the fact
that
what is it 44 of the country probably
wouldn't see me as
as belonging here i feel like you might
be an exception my friend where if
they've seen you in something then all
of a sudden
uh you become familiar to them in a way
that
um that that might hopefully
uh engender you know some
positivity i feel like you'd get that if
you went to a lot of places
and when you were performing your comedy
i feel like you might know this country
in a way that a lot of people don't
because comedians
head to small towns and medium-sized
cities
and work like a club where
like you said like you know a few dozen
drunk people show off
you're there and you're there with a
bunch of other comics and you end up
staying
overnight in places that a lot of
americans will never see and never visit
did you have that experience
as a comedian or were you more
exclusively in chicago and new york
um i certainly had that experience not
as much i couldn't do it in chicago
because i couldn't make money so i would
go sometimes do their shows just to do
them but certainly in new york
i have done tours of tiny tiny towns and
you know i grew up in a really big city
i grew up in karachi which is like 20
million people
i've i lived in chicago i lived and
lived in new york
so i was always very like metropolitan
going to these small towns was really
very eye-opening because i'll be honest
you know before i went to them
i was a little bit i thought oh i
i don't see the appeal like if i lived
there i would move out but then going
there you do a show in a tiny town i did
this show
think of this specific one i i did a
show in a tiny town in ohio
then afterwards everybody went to a bar
and all the people from the show went to
the bar
and i was kind of hanging out and
talking to these people who'd sort of
grown up there
and some of them had been like best
friends with each other since the second
grade you know
and i thought that that was really
beautiful and even
though a lot of these people may not
agree with me politically now
i really i realized that
as trite as this sounds we all truly
have a lot more in common than we don't
i know sometimes it's that gets obscured
by
by um by just the conversation and
and sort of the screaming in each other
but uh i i
it made me feel ultimately optimistic
about about where we're headed
in this grand experiment genuinely think
comedians
uh could be the great unifying force
of our society in part because of of
those experiences that
so many of you have had that's a lot of
pressure to put on a bunch of drunks and
drug addicts dude
just in uh well one place that feels
very very uplifting
and i'd urge you to try and get there
though i guess it'd be far field for
for you uh and you know then you're you
know you're probably not going to you
know break isolation
um but dave chappelle has uh
has a cornfield near his house and he's
been doing live comedy
shows there with uh comedians who just
come and go essentially i think that
their nickname for it was chappelle
summer camp
so yeah it actually takes some of the
ingredients you're describing where
it's a very small town but people are
discovering
it's essentially like a field of dreams
of comedy the whole thing blows your
mind like you go there and because it's
a cornfield everyone's spread out it's
very socially distanced
you're just like what am i seeing i'm
seeing like some of the best comedians
uh in the world in this corn field
uh and it felt quintessentially american
in part because of the backdrop
it's like just fields of corn in the
summer there's a gazebo
anyway so um but but the comedians i i
talk to because they interact with
people the same way you do it's like
look we all
have a lot in common we all want the
same things uh and there are these
political discussions that are trying to
pit us against each other
in a way that i don't think would apply
if we were just sitting across a kitchen
table from each other or if we were in
the same bar at the same night
like then you would just end up bonding
over your common humanity
instead of you know typing some nasty
comment
in twitter facebook or
or what have you um so i'm
i'm serious that i feel like uh
comedians are having a different
conversation with americans
uh than politicians for sure like a
better conversation in many respects
i think that's right i think that's
right um
what you said about you know i one of my
best friends in the world is indian
people always like a pakistani
indian and it's like yeah those lines
don't exist when you're like sitting
next to someone or eating with them you
know i always find like if you look at
the big sick there's a lot of
eating scenes that happen whenever
people uh
whenever walls come down and people
connect and i really feel like you know
if
if the world could if i could
bring some of these people in and and
feed them pakistani food i don't think
they could think of that place in the
way that they think of it right now
because
because our food's too good yes
well said camille's effort will be like
pakistani restaurants across the country
letting people know that this place is
too delicious
to dislike that's right
i mean that is what we are we're too
delicious to dislike
that should be on our flag that that i
mean that's a pretty good tagline
uh comedians and chefs bringing the
world together i don't i don't mind it
uh so when you talk about the politics
of this moment so you've got a green
card
um are you a citizen now or are you
still trafficking and i am in prison now
oh so you have the freaking full rights
and privileges you took the test
was the test as hard as they say no
the test was pretty easy um in fact
why like i don't know how much i could
say because i don't because i read
something where they were like oh we can
start revoking citizenships and all this
stuff
you're in for good don't worry man you
can spill the beans nothing's gonna
happen
it's irreversible i i went in
and i sat with this guy and i was really
nervous and he was an asian
he's an asian guy very nice and uh right
from the beginning he was like
he asked me a couple questions and then
he saw i was nervous and he was like
don't be nervous you're gonna pass don't
worry about this
and i just thought it was really really
sweet like he didn't have to do that he
he didn't have to put me at ease you
know he didn't have to
make me feel better the person who
interviewed us for the green card
certainly didn't do that she was trying
to get us she was trying to get us to
contradict ourselves and
and you know she was like she was
certainly like aggressive
uh but this guy was was super nice so
that that test wasn't
it was not that hard no so yeah i'm here
for good can't get rid of me
yeah look at this full rights and
privileges so
so and you know you're paying oodles and
taxes which will make some people very
happy yeah
california it's a big percentage
uh so you and i connected in part
because there was
uh an asian american political event
we're trying to
rally folks in the community um
do you have a different perspective on
what's going on politically as a result
of the fact that you had to
essentially fight to stay in this
country you become a citizen
uh and then now you are in my mind one
of the most
prominent pakistani american figures
which and i'm i can relate to aspects of
this
because you know there aren't that many
like asian-american
um uh presidential candidates
no not not that many let me see how many
i can think of
yeah there's andrew yang in this um so
uh i feel like you became a citizen just
as our country started to really
um turn against each other or feel like
it's getting torn apart
um and i take it that you're
with so you know about me like i've
endorsed joe and kamala like uh you know
i'm trying to get
folks to just vote vote vote because i
feel like the more people that vote
uh the better off we're going to be
but i feel like you have a different
perspective because you're like a kind
of a recently minted american
just like you had to fight to get it and
then here we are
at this political moment where it feels
like there's a ton
at stake uh in november
yeah you know i always feel like
obviously uh
i relate to immigration issues very
intimately
and this the demonization of immigrants
you remember when they were talking
about the caravan from mexico and stuff
i it never first of all i find it
obviously
moral and immoral and unethical
but on top of that it's also extremely
illogical because
you know you were born here we
had to like fight to come here we chose
america as our home
we gave up our lives you know we put
everything on the line to choose
to choose like better lives for
ourselves and our families i mean
what's more american than that right the
pursuit of
life what is it life liberty happiness
whatever it is i don't remember from the
citizenship
from the test test was too long ago that
was a long time ago
but to me that should be something
that's commended
i mean these people are patriotic they
chose america
they weren't just born here so so i find
that i
i think it just never makes sense to me
that people are able to demonize
immigrants so easily
and yeah obviously this election is very
very important you know my parents
moved here after i did my parents have
been here now
maybe uh like 12 years or so
um and they moved from karachi and they
they landed here and they loved america
you know they were like oh my
god things are like much easier here
they felt really accepted they just my
mom was
like seeing her that happy and that
comfortable it just
brought so much joy to me and then in
the last few years
it's been very difficult for her you
know her relationship to america has
changed and the way she looks
the way she sees america has changed now
when i talk to her
all she does is really talk about
politics and how scared she is
and she says they don't want us here i'm
like
no mom this is like there's a certain
percentage of people
this is not how it is things can turn
very quickly and she was like she said
something that really broke my heart
she's like we already
we already left pakistan where where do
we go from here
where will we go when we have to leave
here that's so heartbreaking
you know she's been here for 12 years
and she's happy for the first 10 years
and then the last two years she's like
wait a minute like i'm not sure if this
place actually
uh wants people like me yeah it's been
it's been really really really
devastating thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you